today we discuss only the big questions
on an especially khofifah show
does God exist is ideology a destructive
parasite have campus snowflakes and
pajama boys destroyed our civilization
dr. Jordan B Peterson will be here to
explain the world then so Rachel Amanda
presto giacomo and Jacob arey joined the
panel of deplorable z-- to talk Trump's
surprise Obamacare smackdown and an
American family freed after being held
hostage by the Taliban for five years
finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I cannot wait to bring on
dr. Jordan Peterson I'm extremely
excited for this show but before we can
we need to welcome our new sponsor
policy genius huzzah hooray they're not
gonna cancel us this week maybe next
week there there actually seems to be a
certain Providence to our sponsors on
this show on the first part of this show
they policy genius.com is the place to
go to learn about life insurance now the
advantages of policy genius make it a
no-brainer you can save up to 40% on
life insurance you can compare quotes
from America's top providers and and
yeah you can save a lot of money so if
you're anything like me your life is in
total disarray in constant peril also
you don't know very much about life
insurance what it costs a lot of people
think it's way more expensive than it is
let me tell you I have seen this up
close no man knows the day or the hour
when your family will need financial
protection I've seen this personally it
made a very strong impression on me on
the need to get life insurance do it now
policy geniuses website makes it as
simple as it can be even I am willing to
do it it takes five minutes to apply for
a quote if you have any questions policy
genius has a team of licensed experts on
hand to walk you through it
there's no hold music there's no press 9
for English there is actual customer
service if you're putting off life
insurance or you want to make sure that
the life insurance you have is right for
you
check out policy genius.com today again
you're gonna you can say 40% by
comparing policy
the quotes are free there's zero sales
pressure there is zero hassle and it
helps us out and helps keep the lights
on so go to policy genius comm is a life
insurance for the 21st century okay now
we have dr. Peterson he is a clinical
psychologist cultural critic and
professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto he may be the
leading University free speech activist
around today but I actually don't want
to talk about that too much because then
we would miss all of the interesting
speech that dr. Peterson has to offer
you know very often that the debate over
free speech it stops right there at the
forum of the speech does someone have
the right to say this or that should the
government should private institutions
censor this or that those questions seem
simple to me and probably to you I want
to get to the content I want to get to
the this and that particularly how
ideology is a terrible terrible thing
dr. Peterson thank you for joining us my
pleasure thanks for the invitation
absolutely so I want to dive right into
it I really admire you and I really
admire all of your work and and I agree
with very much of what you say let's
begin with ideology you have said that
ideology is a parasite that's a
sentiment I with which I thoroughly
agree you've explained the conflict
between ideology and traditional strains
of thought in the West I think most
people even on the right even
conservatives would find that statement
startling what is so bad about ideology
well it provides a one-size-fits-all
answer to every question and there's a
variety of problems with that I mean and
it's one sided biased one-size-fits-all
answer and the bias depends on your
particular ideological stance in some
ways biases themselves aren't as bad as
you might think because they're not that
distinguishable from heuristics which
are simplifications that you need to
operate in the world I mean we can't
operate in the world is in considering
it in all of its complexity we have to
simplify it but there's dangers in the
simplifications and then there's dangers
in a consistently biased simplification
and ideologies are consistently biased
simplifications now the right sometimes
to see part of the reason that
the Western Democratic systems work is
because they allow people who have
specified biases to compete in an open
market of biases election is exactly
exactly so you know sometimes the right
is right
sometimes the extreme right is right
sometimes the left is right so to speak
and sometimes the extreme left is right
the extremes aren't correct let's say
very often sorry go ahead
but there you know there are situations
that arise where less generally
applicable principles may may
sporadically hold but anyways the point
is is that in an exchange of ideas you
get the opportunity for multiple people
to put forward their biased heuristics
they're biased oversimplifications
and to engage in the kind of debate that
raises the resolution of the question
and answer at hand and that's necessary
because the environment is shifting
underneath you all the time and so what
was right yesterday what was correct
yesterday isn't necessarily correct
today and so you have to continually
engage in negotiation and discussion to
stay in the middle let's say in the in
the correct place yeah not to formalize
too much not to abridge too much and you
bring up there are ideologies on the
right we you know we see them they
change some pop up some fall out of
fashion but there has been a question
for a long time the Conservatives have
debated can a real conservative be an
ideologue or should conservatives ground
their their view of the world in
something more substantive than an
ideologies
well I think genuine thinkers should
ground their worldview in something more
substantive than an ideology and one of
the things that I've studied for a very
long period of time is is the
relationship between let's say
ideologies or belief systems for that
matter to the underlying psychological
some structures that the psychologist
psychiatrist Carl Jung described as
archetypal and so you could think of
these archetypal sub structures as the
grand stories by which people conduct
their lives and they're they're
structured in a very particular
they're very balanced stories so for
example in a typical properly
constructed archetypal narrative you
have a represented representation of
nature or chaos or the unknown those are
symbolic categories that are quite
similar they sort of represent what
exists beyond the safety of the campfire
and the town in the city and and
familiar territory you could think about
it as the archetype of unexplored
territory and it's negative and positive
at the same time it's negative because
you better watch your step when you
aren't where you think you are because
you'll die if you're not careful right
and that's the negative element and so
nature can be a vicious brutal force and
everyone who's alive and thinks knows
that but by the same token it's also the
place the unknown and nature is the
place that you can go and explore and
find new and wonderful things go west
young man exactly that's exactly well
and that's an interesting one to bring
up because we'll return to that we'll
return to that because there's a
counter-narrative to that so Nature has
its positive and negative element it's
often represented with feminine symbols
by the way mother nature let's say and
then culture has the same structure
there's like the tyrannical king and the
benevolent king and the tyrannical king
is the part of culture that crushes you
and destroys you and mangles you and
forces you to be a cog in a wheel and
the benevolent part is the part that
educates you and disciplines you and
shelters you and teaches you to speak
and imbues you with all the facets and
traits that a civilized person would
have and again a story that doesn't
involve both of those forces is
incomplete even though they're
contradictory of course and then on top
of that is the individual and in an
archetypal story the individual has a
heroic element and an adversarial
element so in christianity that's
represented by they say in eternal
conflict between Christ and Satan if
you're thinking about it psychologically
it's reflected in the story of Cain and
Abel as well and in typical hostile
brother stories very common narrative
tropes and so a comprehensive view of
the world offers a representation of all
of those elements whereas an ideology
what an ideology does is slice that
representation into a partial
formulation so for example
when feminists talk about the patriarchy
they essentially assumed that the social
world is only a negative force it's only
tyrannical well it is tyrannical but
it's not only tyrannical right and that
that's a right we cannot force an only
tyrannical patriarchy on them
that's right that's exactly it there's
there's too much pushback right and I
mean to think about the social
structures in the West as fundamentally
tyrannical is means that you're either
well ideological II possessed to the
degree that's almost incomprehensible or
that you know absolutely nothing
whatsoever about history or the current
world for that and those may not be
mutually exclusive well and you said go
west young man okay so so let me unravel
out a bit so there's a that's the
frontier narrative so the frontier
narrative is untamed nature positive
culture positive individual so it's the
heroic individual spreading the benefits
of benevolent culture into the wild
untamed wilderness okay so that's an
ideology and it's powerful one because
it draws on these underlying archetypal
symbolic themes that are deeply
motivational meaningful to people but
the counter narrative emerged to that
let's say that was the narrative that
settled the United States okay but the
counter narrative emerged and that's the
environmental narrative the
environmental narrative is benevolent
nature toxic culture adversarial
individual so the this essential
ideological environmental narrative is
terrible human beings that are a cancer
on the planet are spreading their toxic
patriarchy and raping Mother Nature and
I know it gets no coincidence by the way
that the environmental movement as we
see it today really sprung up in the 90s
in the wake of the fall of communism
there was the major ideology of the left
that crumbled before our eyes and now
this new ideology of environmentalism
seems to have largely taken its its
position of prominence well okay so no I
don't disagree I don't disagree and I
think it's actually one of the things
that really pollutes the argument about
in
our mental sustainability you know like
obviously exploiting the planet let's
say in a way that that produces
unsustainable externalize costs is a bad
idea clearly now the timeframe matters
but it's clearly a bad idea the problem
is is that it's almost impossible to
engage in a discussion about
environmental sustainability without
also simultaneously engaging in a
discussion that's anti-capitalist
and so for me as soon as an
environmentalist becomes anti-capitalist
then I can't trust them as an
environmentalist or because I don't know
if their environmentalism it usually is
a cover for their neo Marxism or or
another ideology that's precisely switch
yeah it just pollutes the damn problem
and it's really about it well you can
intended you can make a very strong case
for a conservative environmentalism
conservatism sure yeah well exactly and
and you know the Conservatives are part
of the conservative vague ethos is try
not to do anything too stupid you know
where's the you could say that the
liberal ethos is try actively to improve
things you know and that's great acted
stupidly as you may yeah well in order
to do it well the problem is on the
liberal end of things and this is a
temperamental problem is that many ideas
that are designed to generate solutions
to problems actually generate more
problems right and so an informed
conservative says something like well
yeah there's a problem there but let's
not get ahead of ourselves and presume
that we actually know how to fix it in a
way that won't just make it worse right
right you know what and for me like I'm
kind of temper mentally predisposed to
be more on the liberal left end of
things from a personality perspective
because I'm high in a trait called
openness which is a good predictor of
say liberalism and and more left-wing
thinking although I am also high in
conscientiousness which is a good
predictor of more right-wing thinking
but what really convinced me to become
more of a traditionalist I would say was
this realization of unintended
consequences is that it's very very
difficult to make alterations to a
complex system
in a manner that doesn't make the system
function worse instead of better and so
I think generally speaking that
especially when you're perturbing
extraordinarily complex social systems
that you should be firmly aware of the
limits of your intelligence and the
probability of you're biased
interpretations of course and I love
that you've brought up this term
traditionalism I actually made the case
a couple days ago that I think Donald
Trump himself may be counter-intuitively
exhibits many aspects of traditionalism
in the Edmund Burke Michael Oakshott
sort of sense of things and I wonder if
now as you've noted and channeling
Nietzsche that you know at a certain
point in our culture God died for our
cultural purposes and ideology replaced
it where are we now are we in a post
ideological age is God striking back
against nature well the thing is one of
the things that's really not necessary
to note about Nietzsche is that when he
made the pronouncement that God was dead
it was by no means triumphant of course
yeah so some people misunderstand that a
lot oh definitely the full phrase is is
I'm paraphrasing but the full phrase is
something like God is dead
we have killed him and we'll never find
enough water to wash away the blood
right right right and and and that was
associated with thoughts he had at the
same time that the consequence of the
death of this traditional value
structure on the idea of a transcendent
moral structure and and an ultimate
moral responsibility would be replaced
by two things one would be a kind of
hopeless nihilism and the other would be
a swing especially into leftist
totalitarianism which he directly
predicted as did Dostoyevsky although
that wasn't the only logical
totalitarian outcomes of course so I
mean he had that nailed it's a it's
actually one of the most amazing
prescient predictions that I've ever
encountered indeed in any way do you
find a link between that nihilism that
came came out of the death of God and
left-wing totalitarianism and these
campus snowflakes and the Peter Pan
syndrome and The Pajama Boys this
apathetic malaise
bratty culture that we're seeing among
perfectly luxurious young healthy
wealthy generation well you need a you
need a direction right and and without
that you're bereft certainly a positive
emotion but you're also hyper anxious
you know that that's the thing that's
kind of odd about having direction and
responsibility is that it gives meaning
to your life because it it helps you
understand how the small things you do
everyday are related to crucial and
important goals without that it's very
very difficult to orient yourself in the
world and dr. Peterson oh I'm sorry go
ahead well it also makes you anxious
because there's no limit say and people
say especially people who are high in
openness and low in conscientiousness so
they're the liberal left types they say
well limits are only constraining it's
like no no limits aren't only
constraining like fences keep snakes out
right well as you in examples can work
yes yes well exactly and you know the
funny thing too about the radicals on
campuses is that they just have no
concept conception of how many walls are
protecting them they're inside a wall
often actually a literal wall cuz many
of the campuses are walled and then
they're inside the you know those walls
are inside the city and the city's
inside the state and the state's inside
the government the government is
protected by the military and there's
just and that that's all governed by
tradition there's just wall after wall
after wall and they say well I don't see
any danger what's with all the
restrictions it's like well yeah you
don't see any danger you know you
remember in the in the Lord of the Rings
you may remember this or you may not
the hobbits you know there are these
little people who are sort of
self-satisfied and smug and naive and
and completely ignorant about the
surrounding world and of course there's
evil gathering all around them which is
the archetypal state of mankind and
they're protected by the Striders one of
the most whom is Aragorn and they are
the descendants of ancient kings and
they patrol the boundaries and keep the
hobbits safe and the hobbits know about
them but they just think they're
despicable tramps
so it's brilliant because we are we are
protected by the descendants of ancient
kings or that's what our traditions are
and and people who casually violate a
tradition have no idea what's behind the
wall they have no idea they lack a sense
of history and they certainly lack a
sense of human fallibility and
malevolence and I must note you've
brought up Tolkien and I don't want to
allow the early brief discussion of
Christianity go totally without further
discussion you in in your description of
ideology in your description of
traditionalism of symbols of the
symbolized of the logos as transcendent
and divine if I didn't know any better I
would guess that you were a Catholic you
sound an awful lot like a Catholic and I
wanted to know if you had any thoughts
about that description and if you are oh
well if you aren't yet a Catholic and I
can I be your Godfather
obviously when you Orthodox I've been
contacted by a number of Orthodox Jews
who think that I'm pretty much an
Orthodox Jew and a lot of Orthodox
Christians who think that I'm pretty
much an Orthodox Christian and also a
number of Mormons who think or no sorry
not know who were they Jehovah's Witness
no I don't funny it's because I've been
contacted by people from a lot of
different denominations and they and
they've said the same thing which is
that I'm putting the finger on what they
believe is at the core of their belief
system but you know and I've been
looking at this primarily from a
psychological perspective like I'm not
denying or even commenting on the
underlying metaphysical realities you
know technically speaking because it's
out sort of outside of my domain of
competence I'm not denying their
existence or making a case for their
existence on in my public presentations
but one thing I have discovered is that
there's something really fundamentally
important about the idea of the logos
you know because the logos is the idea
that the individual is the the soul of
the individual and the value of that
soul transcends the value of the state
and that's an amazing proposition I
think that's the central Western
proposition is that the state itself has
no
dominion over the individuals certainly
right we may appeal to heaven as General
Washington once put on a flag so and the
reason that that's so psychologically
significant as far as I'm concerned is
that the state and this has been
realized by a number of cultures in a
variety of different ways the state has
a tendency to become too static right in
state and static or obviously the same
word and without the dynamic
consciousness of the individual
continually transforming expanding the
boundaries of the state the state
collapses into a type of totalitarian
rigidity and then everyone dies so and
if you don't keep the state subservient
in some sense to the free consciousness
that and that's the moral consciousness
of the dedicated citizen then everything
goes to hell and and very very rapidly
and and almost literally because I mean
if you look at places like you know
Stalinist Soviet Union and especially in
the 1930s and Mao's China and Cambodia
and these places where these
totalitarian systems got the upper hand
I mean to describe them as hellish is an
understatement I would say it's oh yeah
it's a world of lies it's a world of
lies that wreaks havoc in hell well well
that's the other thing that's so
interesting is that the the really
informed commentators on those
totalitarian states have drawn a very
direct causal path between the
proclivity of the individual citizen to
falsify their own experience so to lie
by commission and omission and the
emergence of these totalitarian states
so what they essentially make isn't an
economic case or a political case they
make a psychological and ethical case
and that's especially well documented
well Viktor Frankl does a pretty good
job of that in man's search for meaning
and vaclav havel made the same sort of
connection so did Gandhi but I think
it's been best laid out well partly by
Tolstoy who was a huge influence on
Gandhi but most particularly I would say
by Solzhenitsyn in his documentation of
the Gulag Archipelago like his his
entire 1700 page case is that the reason
that the totalitarian state got the
upper hand in the Soviet Union was
fundamentally because too many citizens
decided that it was in their best
short-term interest to lie about
everything including their own suffering
July 2 to themselves I I think you put
it one way I may have read this from you
or from someone else that into the
utopian a suffering is heresy at the
acknowledged suffering as heresy I know
it's that well that's a really great
definition of Hell a hell is the place
where you're in pain and you're punished
for admitting it yeah and even admit it
to yourself of course and that there is
we have all these discussions about
which pronouns we should use which
bathrooms people can use and they seem
to be really highly politicized for
precisely this purpose they say it's
trivial it doesn't mean it's just a
little lie that we're telling each other
what's the big deal but that that is the
big deal when we live in enough lies
when we lie even about our own suffering
you end up in a totalitarian state well
in Europe and you're the totalitarian
and you are that's precisely right you
are an eraser right see I mean one of
the things that Solzhenitsyn documents
in the Gulag Archipelago is his
realization that he was his own tyrant
you know and and it's so fascinating
because he wrote the Gulag Archipelago
when he was in the prison camps and he
basically memorized the book and that's
you know - to memorize the seventeen
hundred page book is really something is
inconceivable especially a book like
that right and he didn't write the book
until he had was struck very hard by the
realization that he was his ethical
faults had directly contributed to the
situation that he found himself in and
you know interestingly enough - he said
that he came to that realization in
large part although not solely by
watching the very few people that he saw
in the prison camps resist the the lie
the demand for lies on the part of their
jailers he said most of those people
were had a deeply rooted religious faith
and and that seemed to enable them to
refuse to cooperate with the authorities
when that cooperation was demanded which
would also preclude them partaking in
such roles as being camp trustees
because in the gulag system
interestingly enough most
the positions of tyranny were held by
the prisoners themselves which is now
there is a great definition of Haley you
know as a prison where all the prison
guards are prisoners well that's
precisely right you which actually I
suppose is the Christian definition of
hell certainly Milton's definition of
Hell this does bring up another point
which is if we are to look at the man in
the mirror and take responsibility for
ourselves and recognize that much of our
suffering and our oppression is it comes
from within and our own ethical failures
then I have to ask this has been a meme
going around the internet for a long
time do I really have to clean up my
room well you don't have to but you have
to suffer the consequences that's right
I mean it's not a great alternative well
that's the thing is that it's you know
it's it's in many situations in life you
get to pick your poison mm-hmm right and
that's really worthwhile knowing because
it isn't that there's a pathway that you
can take that's going to make your life
well let's call it simple and happy
because life whatever life is it's not
simple in half certainly not those
things right no it's it's complex and
tragic and you can ennoble that with a
certain mode of being and and that mode
of being has to be associated with a
willingness to abide by the truth and
like I don't even really think about
these things as ethical Commandments in
some sense I and and it's something
that's also struck me as as a I've
become more and more familiar with
biblical writings is that most of the
time there are simple statements of fact
so imagine you know reality has this
structure it's complex and you can tell
it has a structure because it punishes
you very badly when you do some things
you shouldn't do like you know toddlers
learn very rapidly not to stand up
underneath tables when they're first
learning to walk just a burner on the
stove exactly and the table is always
hard and the burner always burns and so
you can learn to avoid those things
because they're you know they're cut and
dried their walls but no unfortunately
I've lost my train of thought
that's finite but when I imagine the
suffering of every time I push the
burner that
also makes me lose it as well I would
like to take okay well the thing is is
that those those elements of suffering
are built into the structure of the
world the structure of the world is real
and the problem with lying is that you
replace accurate perception of the
structure of the world with a wish an
arrogant wish like the wishes that you
could have things the way that you want
them on my territory that's exactly it
the arrogant part is on my terms
and I'll get away with it and it's such
an absurd proposition because the
probability that you can bend the
structure of reality in your favor
without it having it snap back and hit
you in the face which is I suppose in
some sense a definition of God in a
perverse ways it's zero right in my
clinical practice and I swear that this
is the case and I would say also in my
private life observing people over long
periods of time I have never seen anyone
get away with anything they it always
comes back to haunt them in one form or
another and they may not realize or
understand the causal connection
sometimes that's what psychotherapy is
about but the causal connections are
there and that's the sort of thing that
Solzhenitsyn detailed in the Gulag
Archipelago no no it's so weird because
he was he was a victim of Hitler because
he was on the front lines and then he
was a victim of Stellan and I mean if
you want to make a case for being a
victim that's for sure right and but
instead he decided that he was going to
take the responsibility on himself and
and become one of the greatest men of
the century right well that's that's the
thing that's so incomprehensible is that
that book was that really was there was
a few death blows to the integrity of
the communist system but from an
articulated and and and and verbal
perspective and intellectual perspective
nothing talked the who like archipelago
it took the sub structure out from
underneath any moral claim that
communism had just a glimpse of reality
does it I do I know I said that was the
last question but I actually have one
more do you this is a very practical
question for young people or people who
are wandering around and
is the shallow ideologies and this sort
of nihilism and living in lies whatever
you want to call it what advice would
you give to them is it go worship God is
it read the Bible is it accept the
tragic fact of life how can they pull
themselves out of the mire and wash all
that blood off of us that Nietzsche said
we'd never get off well you know Carl
Jung said something that that is quite
similar to Solzhenitsyn's prescription
which was that with a sufficient moral
effort psychoanalysis was unnecessary I
would say that the best advice that that
I might give to people is that they try
to stop saying things that make them
weak which is a variant of trying to
learn not to lie because if you pay
attention if you pay attention Nietzsche
said who among us has never sacrificed
himself for the sake of his good name
and what he meant by that was well you
know you're in a social circumstance and
you act in a manner that's different
than how you actually feel or you refuse
to put forward your viewpoint or you
can't or you know you falsify yourself
and some of that you know is akin to
being socialized let's say but put that
aside I'm thinking about the
falsification part it's like if you
watch yourself very carefully if you
watch what you say and I would include
your nonverbal behavior in that category
you'll see that certain things that you
say put solid ground under your feet and
certain things turn the ground that
you're standing on into quicksand and
you can feel that in an embodied sense
of something Carl Rogers who's a great
psychiatrist psychologist realized quite
I guess probably in the 50s in the 40s
and that there was an embodied sense and
in some sense that would be equivalent
to the voice of conscience and so you
know when you're betraying yourself you
know when you're weakening yourself and
if you start to pay attention to that
you can learn to stop doing that it's
interesting because I was just reading
Socrates apology which is his did the
description of his the trial that
eventually ended in his death and his
reaction to that his heroic reaction to
that and he talked about the thing that
differentiated him from other people and
he said well he had this in turn
voice which he called a daemon obviously
is related to the word demon right it
wasn't that it's an internal spirit an
internal voice and he always listened to
it and it never told him what to do but
it told him what not to do and so if the
internal voice objected to something he
was doing or saying he would stop he
would stop doing him he would stop doing
it he'd reformulate it and so the reason
he didn't defend himself at his trial
interestingly enough is because his
internal voice and and leave because
really they just wanted him to get the
hell out of Athens because he was a
troublemaker
so they warned him long ahead that he
was going to be tried and found guilty
essentially and his friends told him to
leave and he went and consulted his
Damon and it said no don't don't leave
and he thought like well what what the
hell exactly and then he thought it
through and he thought well he was
getting very old and and maybe the gods
had granted him the opportunity to step
out of life gracefully and put his
affairs in order and so on you know I
mean you can think about it as a
rationalization but it was Socrates that
we're talking about so I wouldn't do
that too quick of course but I must say
my internal voice is telling me not to
end this interview for several more
hours because it is just so illuminating
and I could talk to you all day long but
unfortunately the voice of Ben Shapiro
in the next room saying that we need to
close off the show is the one that
writes my checks so unfortunately well
we'll have to end it here dr. Peterson
thank you so much for coming on this has
been a wonderful discussion and I hope
that we can have you back thanks a lot
for the invitation and for the
discussion absolutely make sure to
everyone who's watching you go to
youtube and watch every one of dr.
Peterson's videos and listen to his show
it's really really excellent some of the
best commentary out there and we have a
whole panel of deplorable 'z and we have
the mailbag there is so much more for
you all to see but you can't see it
unless you go to the Daily wire calm I
know what you were thinking you are
thinking I want to watch this on
Facebook I want to watch this on YouTube
well it's $10 a month $100 a year you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show yeah
yeah but look at this look at what you
get you get the leftist tears tumblr
this is actually the tumblr out of which
Socrates drank the hemlock and the
hemlock was those leftist tears they
couldn't take all of his truth bombs so
we drank it like a courageous man this
is the finest vessel for leftist tears
out there you have to go over right now
and we will be right back
there is some excellent news thank you
so much panel sorry we took a little bit
longer but I I couldn't stop talking to
dr. Jordan Peterson that guy is like the
most interesting guy ever we have from
The Daily wire Amanda Prestage jacquimo
from The Daily wire also we have Jacob
berry and then we have the incomparable
one-and-only Zoo Rachel let's get right
into the news president Trump announced
today that after Congress's failure to
repeal Obamacare he would now use all of
the executive power at his disposal to
reduce the regulations and free up
American businesses and just take out
some of the burden of Obamacare that he
can do from the White House Amanda is
this the sort of bold action that is the
reason we elected Donald Trump or is he
overstepping his bounds no this is this
is good stuff and he's doing this with
Rand Paul so he's about as libertarian
as you're gonna get in Congress so so we
know that it's gonna be constitutional
as well basically just expect he's
repealing regulation and Rand Paul was
talking about it today is that just
basically exploiting a law from the
1970s that any president could have done
since then and just allows people to
kind of small businesses for instance
can now pull together from different
states to provide insurance coverage for
their employees and then also now you
don't have to have like if you're I
don't know like a 20 year old man right
you don't have to have a maternity care
so it's still gonna have it just to be
safe frankly I just don't want to get
caught without it but it's nice yeah
riskier yeah it's great just keep
repealing as much as you can of course
Congress is terrible so it's kind of
like led to this but anything with Rand
Paul involved it's gonna be a pretty
decent maybe you know polling back or
regulation it's gonna be constitutional
so this is this is good stuff I love it
Jacob what do you think is this
executive order going to accomplish
anything some executive orders haven't
accomplished that much Amanda's pretty
bullish on here what do you think I
agree with Amanda I think it does
accomplish a lot I noticed that all of a
sudden they Rand Paul haters on the
Trump train are very silent about this
that they're very on board and excited
about
and I think it does if if Obama used his
executive orders to expand Obamacare I
think it's personally reasonable to say
hey president Trump you can use the
power of the pen to dismantle Obamacare
I don't see a problem with this and I I
think it'll help Republicans get in gear
finally mm-hmm and president Trump he
has a pen and a phone a huge pen and a
huge phone so why won't Congress Act why
are they going to give President Trump
all of the credit for repealing all
these terrible Obamacare regulations oh
man you know there's a little bit of an
ego trip involved in a little power
turtle ball but I think what would be
really cool is if they get that wall
built and then go ahead and Trump could
have his like health care plan he could
like even contract like a bunch of
artists and then just go ahead and like
graffiti like his health care plan on
the wall I think it would think both of
which digestible to the public at large
and that's subtlety in the in the age of
Trump you know it is the largest
physical structures in human history
with just gigantic words written across
them I believe it on another strange
news story an American woman and her
Canadian husband who were held hostage
by militants by the Taliban in
Afghanistan for five years have been
freed along with their children and we
I'm sorry we worked with Afghanistan and
Pakistan on this so this does raise one
question what the hell were these people
doing in Pakistan in Afghanistan with
their young children the woman was
pregnant well you know I got a week
between Christmas and New Year I I will
say all that blank book money is gone so
it's really heartwarming it's like a
Thomas Kinkade painting a peer it--
Jakob Trump has been pretty good at
freeing Americans who have been held
hostage overseas
he got otto warmbier free to North Korea
he got an Egyptian American woman freed
out of Egypt now this family why is he
so good at this why has he had been so
successful where Barack Obama has not
been
well I think it's because Trump says
what he means it's not like it's not
like President Obama or fresh it's a
former President Obama he was like a
helicopter parent I'm gonna give you to
the count of three one two one two over
and over again Trump just goes one two
three BAM and it's nine and one three
exactly and so in this case they
realized that he's serious that they
wanted I mean that Moab bomb dropped on
Isis that the world heard that and I
think that was one of his greatest place
because now when he says you better let
this person go the the country listens
and he gets and they get out and he uses
it to his advantage he plays a little
crazier than I think he is and clearly
it's to his advantage people do do
wonder if the guy's out of his mind a
man the president Trump claimed after
this that America is quote finally being
respected again is that true is that a
fair assessment yeah no I think that's
true especially if you just look at how
we're handling you know I mean Isis is
being obliterated right now nobody's
talking about that but like Jacob was
saying I mean we are taking a stronger
front in foreign policy and we're
actually letting our men fight and you
know lessening rules of engagement and
stuff like that so we actually have I
mean we have the capability to wipe out
a Isis we just didn't before so now
we're actually doing that that's one
example so you know president Trump kind
of you know we're not leaving from
behind anymore he's taking action I
think that that kind of helps us with
greater standing in the world even if
President Trump does say things that you
want to criticize like for instance his
whole Twitter account like it does have
you ever seen a skinny person drinking
diet coke I don't think so actions speak
louder and that's what's making America
America again it's not his Twitter feed
to be honest em a ga folks all right
there was a short panel but
unfortunately I got to get to the
mailbag thank you all for being here and
enlightening illuminating expert if FA
panel as always Amanda presto Giacomo
Jacob airy and zou Rachel now we must
get to the mailbag
hey Michael settling a debate here do
you think modern and future medical
advances will allow humans to live as
long as sea turtles and if so what are
the implications that would arise from
such expanded lifetimes thanks Bill I
don't know I suppose so might be the
case we are living much much longer I
think the question that comes out of
that is why would you want to are you
sure that you want to live forever
humans have always tried to live forever
tried to discover the Fountain of Youth
and the secrets to immortality but this
is a problem that is we were talking
with dr. Peterson comes out of a
nihilistic age out of an age in which
god god is dead and you think that when
you hit the end of the age of 80 or 85
then you turn to worm food and take a
dirt nap and the lights go out but I
certainly don't think that I think
there's everlasting life and why would I
want to be stuck here with Marshall for
another hundred years when I could grow
up and hang out with st. Peter you know
so we'll see but I won't stick around
too long to see any of it I don't think
from Brendan mr. steel the only good
Noel's you have good taste sir what is a
typical day like for you from Brendan
great question I usually roll over
pretty early about 11:15 I'll stumble
out and I'll have my morning meatballs
and my morning whiskey well my fiance
sweet little ELISA writes my show for me
then I'll roll in for a typical work day
I'll punch in about 12:15
punch out about 2:00 you know then I
guess the rest of the day is followed by
some light reading a season or two of
always sunny 15 cigars and a bottle of
port then I I do have to make sure I get
my rest I need my beauty sleep after
that so it's demanding but you need
structure otherwise you're just not
going to be productive so just like dr.
Peterson says make sure you clean your
room I don't clean my room but obviously
someone does for me and and you'll
you'll have a good and productive life
from mark dear Michael Knowles I really
like your interviewing style thank you
this became most apparent to me when you
interviewed James Alsip about the
Charlottesville protests do you have any
advice or resources
on how to give an interview like you did
with him you were relevant and
challenging without being overbearing in
your opposition and even when you would
cut him off
it was more to keep him on topic and on
track than to talk over him
Thank You Marc I appreciate the
compliment I actually do somewhat regret
cutting James off as much as I did in
that interview you are right I only cut
him off because I felt we had limited
time he was evading certain questions or
veering off track I wanted to keep him
on track but the thing that I really
enjoy about interviews is I really like
people I really am curious about people
I'm fascinated by people that's why I
been an actor and I like politics a lot
so that that is the one common thing you
have to like truth and you have to like
people there so there are a couple kinds
of interviews you can do the SmackDown
interview where you you just want to
score points that's a debate interview
yeah that's right this job interview but
there's without one where you just want
to win the points and smack them down
and I don't have any interest in that
that isn't my personality I don't stand
personally to gain anything from that
the other kind of interviews where you
learn something or you convince somebody
of something as I to do with James but
I'm interested to hear what people have
to say and I'd like to convince them so
I think if you have an interest in
people a genuine interest in what they
have to say I think your conversations
are going to be better and your debates
are going to transform into something
that actually is productive and not a
bunch of ignorant jerks yelling at each
other on Facebook or something from Dave
hey Noel's I've started reading books
more you ought to try mine reasons to
vote for Democrats a very nice book for
a quick read I'm worried that it's
becoming a waste in the sense that I'm
not doing anything practical especially
when I read fictional novels while I
enjoyed reading now I feel like I've
wasted time I could have been doing
other things
this is the same feeling I had when I
used to play loads of video games would
like your thoughts Dave what you should
read better books if you're if you
finally there's nothing worthwhile
coming out of them I've I don't read a
lot of fiction myself I should read more
fiction because you
some of the books that have shaped my
view of the world that have influenced
me to the point of really turning into a
different person or a more aware person
our fiction or Crime and Punishment
Dostoevsky obviously Shakespeare and
Dante and Milton so fiction is really
important but you have to read good
fiction if you if you read slowly I read
very slowly just make sure you pick out
decent books it's the most worthwhile
thing you could possibly do because it
will for not a lot of money and for not
a lot of effort totally expand your your
view of the universe and of physics and
metaphysics now I have a special offer
for you it's funny that you asked this
question today because Andrew Clavin has
a new book out it's it's really a story
called another Kingdom and he and I have
been working together to record this
story it had you can't purchase it in
hardcover yet we're releasing it as a
podcast and we're releasing it tomorrow
so we're releasing it on October 13th
you'll be able to get the first episode
then it's really been a lot of fun it's
about a Hollywood schlub who can't catch
a break can't work in show business I
don't know where drew got the idea to
cast me in this and so he stumbles into
another land another Kingdom with crazy
mythological beasts and warlocks and and
all of these sorts of things and I can
certainly attest living here in
Hollywood it is not clear which place is
more surreal or terrifying so check that
out tomorrow then and you can mow the
lawn or do whatever you like because
you'll be listening to it don't read
books have me read books to you from
Lucas my wife and I are expecting a new
baby very soon
congratulations and as I have done in
the past I'm buying a box of cigars to
give to friends and family to celebrate
we're waiting to find out the sex of the
baby who knows it could be years before
we know the gender and I'm fairly well
versed with cigars but do you have any
recommendations that's wonderful news
for that occasion for you I would smoke
my father it's a cigar called my father
by Don Peppino it's reasonably priced
very good seems fitting in terms of non
Cuban stuff I've been smoking a lot of
went a grand reserve a recently Ashton
VSG if you're giving it out to your
friends and family I would I would
myself I'd be a huge cheapskate and I
would go I think the best value for your
buck is Oliva series V in that little
perfecto sighs or a Toro reboost oh
those are excellent cigars and they're
pretty reasonably priced as for Cubans
lately haven't smokin a lot of Monte
Cristo's the 80th anniversary oh is one
of my favorite cigars the limited
edition 2016 Dante I just had in the UK
is very good the onions are expensive
don't waste those on your buddies give
them the Oliva that'll be an excellent
cigar and pretty cheap from Sean when
social justice warriors are triggered on
international Talk Like a Pirate Day are
they obligated to say shiver me triggers
just curious on your opinion Sean is
Jack Sparrow a transsexual duh the
answer is obvious man of course from
Bridget in nomine Patri said feely at
speedy to Santi amend your st. Michael
Noel's patron of trolls two of my
co-workers have recently put signs on
their office doors one of them says hate
has no home here for I like love Trump's
hate or something like that never got
that expression by the way seems
pro-trump they use it as antitrump they
don't know anything in several different
languages and the other is from the
campus LGBTQ LMNOP ia organisation that
says the office is a safe space
I would like to troll them back with the
sign of my own but I'm not sure what to
get I work in a state-funded Law College
so I don't think anything blatantly
partisan would be acceptable please send
to suggestion my way well if you'd work
at a state law College all right what I
would do is put up a nice copy of a very
scholarly political tome in the window
called reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide and that will
contribute to the tone of scholarship
and seriousness at your office but in
general though you got to do something I
don't have the answer for you right now
but you this is not the time to be timid
this is not the time to let these guys
run over you we are winning the culture
right now conservatives are winning the
culture for the first time in my life
for the first time in a very long time
don't give them an inch don't give them
one inch don't give them one little lie
just as Jordan Peterson said don't give
them anything was pretty soon
one light turns into a million you'll be
living in lies hit them back we are
winning despite despite the constant
negative press cough fa absolutely keep
going and I look forward to seeing what
you come up with oK we've got to make
sure that you tune in for the
conversation that is going to be next
week it's gonna be the Andrew Klavan
conversation you can only submit
questions and have your questions
answered if you subscribe to the daily
wire so everybody can watch it it's
gonna be broadcast everywhere Facebook
YouTube it's gonna be October 17th
anybody can watch it but only
subscribers can have their questions
answered drew is just for an hour he's
gonna go through all of the questions so
have the pearls of wisdom from the
Supreme Leader of the multiverse be
dispensed upon you and tune in for the
conversation and subscribe before then
so you can get your questions answered
also speaking of the ruler of the
multiverse another kingdom comes out
tomorrow that's that book that drew and
I have been working on he wrote
everything I perform it it's gonna be
out somewhere tomorrow I'll post the
link to my Twitter Michael J Knowles and
to Drew's as well and Facebook pages but
it's the finally the cure for the Clavin
last weekend there may be a chance that
there will not be chaos or mayhem on
this weekend for the first since Andrew
Clavin started going away so make sure
you tune in for that that's our show
come back next week we'll do it all
again
I'm Michael Noel's this is the Michael
Nolt show thanks for coming
[Music]
[Music]